kamala harris is speaking tonight at the
democratic national convention
she's running for president technically
vice president but yeah
we haven't seen her remarks just yet
they haven't sent us an early copy
but we're pretty sure going out on a
limb here that they will sound
nothing like the kamala harris of 2013.
watch this we run around with these
signs build more schools less jails
build more schools less jails and we
walk around everywhere
build more school we protest build more
schools less jails
put money into education not prisons
there's a fundamental problem with that
approach in my opinion
and it's this i agree with that
conceptually
but you have not addressed the reason i
have three padlocks on my front door
there should be serious and severe and
swift
consequence to crime
serious and severe consequences for
crime trigger warning that sounds racist
okay
it does that's a tool of oppression
and kamala harris appears to have come
to that conclusion here she is speaking
this summer
see if you can spot the difference
part of what has been upside down in
policing policy in america
is that we have confused having
safe communities with hiring more cops
on the street
so if you're a business owner just an
american who lives in the city is afraid
of getting
killed in a riot or having your store
burned down kamala harris wants you to
shut up
and understand racial justice
and so the people protesting on this
street
are protesting understanding
that we have yet to fulfill that promise
of equal justice under the law
colin harris has changed a lot
how why which version is better daniel
preno is in washington tonight for our
convention coverage with the washington
monument and the white house planner
dana it's great to see you tonight thank
you so much
so the old kamala harris of 2003
i think is maybe more in line with most
americans but i wonder
if we've solved for the reasons she's
got three padlocks on her front door
in other words a tape like that is going
to seems to me strike a lot of people
it's like pretty sensible compared to
what she's saying now
and see and that's an interesting point
because i i think it was on your show
and i know that we talked about it on
the five there was the poll that i think
it was uh i think was pew poll or maybe
it was gallup
that said that black americans actually
want more police
than less police and fewer police in
their um communities because they know
that
security means that then they can do all
the other things that they want to do
which is to get good education start
businesses raise happy families
i think that however if people
want to attack harris from this
perspective that she was a really tough
prosecutor and now she's pretending that
she wasn't
i almost think that for people that
maybe undecided or suburban women might
say
that sounds kind of reasonable to me
that sounds good i think republicans
might want to if they want to attack her
it might be more that she's
obviously turned radical left whatever
they're going to say what will be
interesting tonight is that if you think
tucker if aoc is the future of the party
and joe biden is
the past then kamala harris is the
present
right now and they're caught between the
ideology transforming and transitioning
and evolving between where she was even
in 2011 in the tape that you just showed
and where she is today huh so i said
really quick
we're get there are reports tonight that
barack obama is just going to unleash in
a way that former presidents don't
ever on the current president do you
think that's true what would that mean
have you ever seen that happen
well it's not something that the guy
that i worked for uh george w bush has
not
done that but bill clinton did really
try to go after mitt romney i think if
you'll remember that
in 2012 and it was pretty skillful
actually at doing so
the other thing that barack obama
apparently is going to talk about a lot
tonight
is he's going to accuse republicans of
voter suppression efforts
and he's going to tell young people that
they absolutely must resist this they
have to get around
it they have to get out there and vote
so i think you will expect to see that
and i
imagine you'll be talking about it on
your show tomorrow night
yeah because it's alabama 1956 it always
is
danny prinno great to see you thanks
have a good night